good morning everybody it is seven
o'clock it was a day of high drama
multiple calls for the prime minister's
resignation many more questions about
exactly which events the pm attended a
party leader being chucked out of the
commons and a joke about jimmy savile
from the man leading the country as
boris johnson faces the prospect of
being questioned by police we'll get
reaction on today's show from the deputy
prime minister dominic raab the labour
leader zakir stama the lib dem leader
set ed davey and the snp westminster
leader ian blackford plus the former
shadow foreign secretary jack straw who
knows only too well what it's like to
live through a pm being questioned by
the police it's tuesday the 1st of
february
the jury is still out senior
conservatives round on the pm after sue
grey pinpointed failures of leadership
in downing street
police probe 12 lockdown gatherings and
300 photos as officers prepare to
contact those who attend which could
mean speaking to the prime minister
mr speaker
i get it and i will fix it
the jury's still out because we haven't
come to the end of this process
prime minister heads to ukraine today
but does he leave his troubles behind
him he spoke to tory mps last night to
try and head off a leadership challenge
i'm live at scotland yard to analyze
exactly what the met police will be
investigating
the pm heads to kiev to try to solve the
crisis in ukraine after a phone call
with russia's president putin was
cancelled in the wake of gray
you're very welcome to join us wherever
you're watching us around the world this
morning whether it's in iceland or
africa word up why there's a new lease
of life for the hit game wordle how easy
do you find it depends really on the day
doesn't it always start with a dub and
the skylines of four chinese cities have
been lit to mark the lunar new year and
the beginning of the winter olympics
[Music]
good morning everybody the prime
minister will attempt to put the
dramatic events of yesterday behind him
as he heads to ukraine today to try to
stop a russian attack but has he stopped
an attack on his own leadership he faces
being questioned by police after sue
gray released parts of her report into
lockdown party allegations which
pinpointed failures of leadership senior
conservatives say the jury is still out
on his future after multiple calls for
the prime minister's resignation but he
met back benchers last night in an
attempt to shore up support for his own
position
the deputy prime minister dominic raab
and labour leader shakir stama on the
show this hour first let's remind you of
some of the key points that you are
waking up to today they look a little
bit like this police are investigating
12 of the 16 alleged gatherings sue grey
is looking at the prime minister
reportedly attended at least three of
those events but was he at a fourth as
well it's reported that pm's wife carrie
held a party on the 13th of november in
the downing street flat after dominic
cummings left downing street this is the
one of the events the met is looking
into the metropolitan police says
officers will be contacting those who
attended the events to hear their
accounts that could even mean the prime
minister being questioned face to face
officers have received more than 300
images from the cabinet office to review
they've also been sent more than 500
pages of information top civil servant
sue gray's report concluded that there
were failures of leadership and judgment
by different parts of number 10 and the
cabinet office here's john craig
a late-night return to 10 downing street
for boris johnson after a bruising day
in the commons when he was accused of
failures of leadership in sue gray's
scathing report
and as the prime minister embarks on a
trip to ukraine today the metropolitan
police is now investigating 12 alleged
parties with the aid of 300
you very photos
in the comments mr johnson said sorry mr
speaker
i get it and i will fix it but the pm
faced anger from his predecessor
what the grey report does show is that
number 10 downing street was not
observing the regulations they had
imposed on members of the public
so either my right honourable friend had
not read the rules or didn't understand
what they meant and others around him or
they didn't think the rules applied to
number 10 which was it
[Applause]
after two hours in the commons and then
an hour behind closed doors with tory
mps the pm is being warned the partygate
row is far from over the truth is the
jury's still out because we haven't come
to the end of this process what i will
say is that i saw
signs there important signs of an
acknowledgement that more needs to be
done and an acknowledgement that he had
to comply with the recommendations made
in sue grey's report the people that
couldn't say goodbye to a loved one
that's going to stay with them for the
rest of their life and i need to reach a
conclusion that i can explain to them so
i want to see all of the facts
before i reach my decision after
sugree's damning verdict the pm's
leadership is under threat once again
but he's defiantly rejecting calls to
quit john craig sky news
we sent tomorrow down to downing street
as well she is joining us now um
um katie as you as well as you can see
is at new scotland yard for us this
morning ladies good morning good morning
let's go to dining street first of all
um should we uh
pm was in the commons yesterday but he's
heading out the country today tomorrow
that's right and the question is does he
leave his troubles behind him the
problem with the sue grey report is it
doesn't really draw a line under
anything the prime minister's critics
who were hoping for a stick of political
dynamite that would blow up his
premiership didn't get that because sue
gray couldn't tell us many of the
details she was so severely limited as
she put it by the fact that the police
investigation is going on but on the
other hand his allies who wanted to say
look there's nothing much to see here
couldn't really say that either because
we've got 12 of these gatherings
investigated by the police including
at least three that the prime minister
was at himself that is the infamous
birthday party with the cake the
gathering back in may 2020 the bring
your own booze one that there was an
email to staff about and
one actually not in downing street
office but upstairs in the downing
street flat where the prime minister
lives with his family that happened on
the 13th of november of that year when
dominic cummings left and it's alleged
that there was a victory party in which
the abba song the winner takes it all
was playing out they are among those
that are being investigated so there's
no world in which the prime minister is
not wounded and damaged by this but
talking to tory mps last night k he met
tory mps to try and shore up their
support after some angry exchanges in
the commons the sense i got is that he
fights on for now possibly not for that
long if the police investigation comes
back and says that he broke the law or
any damaging photos emerge but certainly
the sense of an immediate leadership
challenge seems to have been headed off
but he's been told that he's on notice
and he's expected to make big changes to
the way his operation runs okay tomorrow
thank you casey um what is it exactly
that the police are investigating and
how long is it going to take
well good morning cayman really the
first thing the police say they are
going to do is go through this enormous
kind of evidence dump they say they have
now
received in relation to these alleged
parties 500 pages of evidence they say
they have received things like whatsapp
messages as well as 300 photographs we
have been hearing rumors for a couple of
weeks now that there are photographs of
these gatherings i don't think anybody
uh realized it was going to be quite uh
this much of course they might have come
under criticism for saying initially
they didn't have the evidence to
investigate that has now they say
changed commander catherine roper said
last night they only received this
evidence on friday
we had a bundle of material provided to
us just friday
which is well over 500 of pieces of
paper about a room and a half we
received and over 300 photographs
what they will do after that they say is
use that evidence that they are
analyzing to decide who they need to
contact to speak to further
about these gatherings they say as part
of the investigation it is necessary for
us to contact those who attended to get
their account now it's understood
initially that will be by email people
will be sent questionnaires to fill out
but the met have not at this stage ruled
out in-person interviews now we know
that tony blair is a sitting prime
minister was interviewed as a witness it
is a big if but if boris johnson was to
be interviewed in person uh under
caution by the met police in relation to
these parties he would be the first
sitting prime minister to have done so
now of course as tamara said the mets
are investigating 12 alleged gatherings
that took place across eight different
dates the one that really is going to be
potentially a big problem for the prime
minister is that november the 13th 2020
gathering the met say they are
investigating an alleged gathering in
boris johnson's private flat very hard
to explain away in terms of a work event
or anything like that the met police
have said though this investigation is
going to take weeks not months so we
could be expecting some conclusions from
them fairly soon
okay ladies for now thank you both
let's take a more detailed look at some
of the events in downing street for
united should we look something like
this
16 events fell within sue gray's
investigations remit 12 of which are now
being investigated by the metropolitan
police
looking at four of them in particular
20th of may 2020 during the first
national lockdown boris johnson's
principal private secretary martin
reynolds reportedly invited more than
100 staff to an event in the downing
street garden staff were told to make
the most of the lovely weather and bring
their own drinks
on the 16th of april last year 30
downing street staff reportedly drank
alcohol in the early hours
at two separate events one of them was a
leaving do for the prime minister's
former director of communications james
slack who later apologized an
attendee was reportedly sent shopping
with a suitcase to fill with bottles of
wine the events took place the night
before the queen was forced to sit by
herself at prince philip's covert
restricted funeral
meanwhile the most recent event to come
to light was on the prime minister's
birthday on the 19th of june
of 2020. downing street admitted staff
gathered briefly inside number 10 the
cabinet room saying boris johnson had
been there for less than 10 minutes
up to 30 people are thought to have
attended the event where boris johnson
is said to have been presented with a
cake while the staff sang happy birthday
yesterday the prime minister faced the
full backlash from those events in the
commons as the pm had to contend with
heavy criticism from across the house
what the grey report does show
is that number 10 downing street was not
observing the regulations they had
imposed on members of the public
so either my right honourable friend had
not read the rules or didn't understand
what they meant and others around him or
they didn't think the rules applied to
number 10 which was it i have to tell
him he no longer enjoys my support the
public know this is a man they can no
longer trust
he has been investigated by the police
he misled the house he must no
i drove for three hours from
staffordshire to kent
only 10 people at the funeral many
people who loved her had to watch online
i didn't hug my siblings i didn't hug my
parents i gave a eulogy
and then afterwards i didn't even go to
her house for a cup of tea i drove back
three hours from kent to staffordshire
does the prime minister think i'm a fool
goodness still to come on the program
for you failures of leadership and
judgment in downing street uh we'll be
speaking to the um deputy prime minister
dominic raab about the latest on the
party's investigation
also speaking engaging reaction to that
long-awaited report from the leader of
the labour party kiyostama he's joining
us at 10 to 8.
the smp's leader in westminster in
blackford will be joining me later this
morning to give his verdict on
yesterday's events in the commons
and at 9am next monday the 7th of feb
the education secretary nadim zahar we
will be here to answer all of your
questions you can send them to us via
twitter or email your questions if you'd
like to or send us a video clip uh you
can email us at
ask the education secretary at sky
dot uk
boris johnson will travel to kiev today
to hold talks with the ukrainian
president about the rising tensions on
the country's border with
russia let's find out more about it
should we both the pm and the foreign
secretary liz truss were you to travel
to kiev today but having tested positive
for covid yesterday after appearing in
the house of commons ms trust will no
longer make the journey meanwhile at a
meeting of the united nations security
council there were angry exchanges
between the u.s and russia
russia has assembled a massive military
force of more than a hundred thousand
troops along the ukraine along ukraine's
border
these are combat forces and special
forces prepared to conduct offensive
actions into ukraine you
are almost calling for this as if you
want to make your words become a reality
where did you get the figure of a
hundred thousand troops
we have never cited that figure we've
never confirmed that figure
let's get more with our defense and
security editor deborah haynes standing
by for us hi deborah a very good morning
to you we our prime minister is heading
out to kiev today to try to sort this
out as far as he is concerned where are
we
yes this is supposed to be a really big
moment for boris johnson in terms of his
personal involvement in a crisis that is
being described as one of the greatest
security crises for europe since the end
of the cold war and yet he hasn't got
off to a great start he was supposed to
have a phone call with uh russian
president vladimir putin yesterday but
given all that he had to do in
responding to the sugree um update he
had to delay that call so that was
supposed to sort of be ahead of this
great big meeting today in kiev but he
still i mean he was supposed to be going
to his with his foreign secretary who
like you said unfortunately has tested
positive for covert so he's staying back
at home however it has to be said that
the uk has has so far played a leading
role in the ukraine response so i'm sure
he'll get a warm welcome
lovely thanks very much indeed deborah
thank you
looking at some of today's other
headlines for united the main suspect in
the disappearance of madeleine mccann
has said it would have been absurd for
him to have abducted her because it
would have risked his activities as a
drug dealer christian b who is serving a
seven year sentence for rape told a
german documentary he wasn't caught for
drug dealing because he was careful
writing from prison he said i was never
caught by the police because i followed
he's in prison remember followed a few
key principles abducting someone was
just as absurd to me at that time as
starting a nuclear war or slaughtering a
chicken
the department of health is warning that
measles vaccinations rates have dropped
to their lowest level in a decade more
than one in ten children in england
still haven't had both doses by the time
they start school putting them at risk
of the potentially fatal disease
and the judge in the sexual assault case
against prince andrew has made a formal
request for his former assistant to give
evidence
lawyers for virginia dufrese had
requested assistance to obtain the
testimony she accuses the prince of
sexually assaulting her when she was 17.
he denies all the allegations
deputy pm's with us uh so much to talk
to you about good morning you got the
draw this morning didn't you um the pm
said yesterday he gets it and he will
fix it what does that actually mean well
the sugray report has been published in
full as he undertook to do it set out a
series of points which uh with
contrition and further apology the prime
minister fully accepted he's talking
about in particular what we're going to
do to correct and remedy some of the
problems sugray highlighted he's going
to set up an office of the prime
minister in downing street if you look
at the history of number 10 over
successive uh governments and years uh
the combination of it being the nerve
center of the whole of government as
well as the prime minister's office has
if you like blurred or at least left
unclarified key lines of responsibility
so he's correcting that with the new
permanent secretary he's reviewing the
the code of conduct for civil servants
but also for special advisers that will
look not just at are there any gaps that
the grey report highlights but how it's
enforced in practice
and more broadly looking at how uh
number 10 and cabinet
function how it reports to parliament i
think it's a comprehensive set of
proposals and at the same time he's
getting on with the job
with the vaccine roll out the economy
and of course you're dealing with
ukraine as you've already said are you
content to sit there and say that he's
published the full report
well he's published the full report he's
been given well that's a completely
different deputy prime minister as we
both know well forgive me but he's in
the hands of sue gray she's provided
this will he publish a full report once
the police have finished yes if there's
any subsequent findings from sugar and
he was clear about that today okay and
just want to remind you and our viewers
we never get tired of looking at this
clip from the 8th of december
i can understand
how infuriating it must be to think that
the people who have been setting the
rules have not been following the rules
mr speaker because i was also furious to
see that clip
i have been
repeatedly assured
since these allegations emerged
that there was no party
and that
and that no
kovid rules were broken
first he didn't know
then it was a work event then no one
told him it was a party then he was
ambushed by a cake then we had to wait
for sue gray now we have to wait for the
full report what next well look he's
waited for sue because as an independent
investigation that's the right thing to
do in relation to i think there are 12
incidents which relate to specific
alleged or claimed breaches it's right
that sue gray has said that's for the
police to look at these are things out
of our control but if you're going to
have a prime minister was allegedly at
least three of those but well again
allegedly but look if you're going to
have how many pastors do you do you
think he was out well look i i think the
point here how many parties so can all
the cabinets okay okay i'll say every
question you've got i always do but look
the point is uh if there are any claims
that need to go to the police and sue
grey has referred 12 that's fine but
they need to be looked at independently
and you can't then blame the prime
minister or the government for not
rushing the police to do their job we'd
be in a whole world of other criticism
if we did that they have the time in the
space no one wants that investigation to
clue more swiftly than us um but it must
be done on their terms but deputy prime
minister he told us there were no
parties then he as i said i went through
the whole list i don't need to go
through it again and now the police are
investigating 12 events well i think
it's right if there's any question marks
and there's been a whole range of
and there's been a whole range of claims
to ascertain the facts to ascertain the
facts as to whether
anything that breached the law has taken
place it's right that the police do that
but they need the time and space to do
so and in any event the government let
alone the prime minister can't control
what the police do that wouldn't be
right okay well let me put this to you
that jess phillips said yesterday in the
house
was the prime minister present
at the event in his flat
on the 13th
of november i assume he doesn't need
other people to tell him whether he was
there or not
um was he at the flat event listed in
the report on the 13th of november do
you need the police to tell him that
well he doesn't need the police telling
that but if he does start answering
specific questions that have been
referred to the police he will be
accused in fact fairly and rightly of
prejudicing or preempting or interfering
in that investigation which is why just
fix penalty notices well there's still
the law look you can't have it both ways
okay you can't say on the one hand the
uh the sanctions are not very high and
on the other hand it's a very serious
issue we take it very seriously those
incidents have gone to the point in
which case you need to be allowed the
time to investigate in which case
it's very serious as you said in your
own words so he should step down if he's
found guilty of any of those offenses
and let's wait and see what
which is allow the police to conduct
their investigation and see when they've
ascertained the facts quite what uh they
conclude and of course there'll be full
transparency around that and look i get
your frustration the public's
frustration no one is watching mine i'm
asking these questions on behalf of them
and i think they're public i think we
want this done and dusted as soon as
possible okay well this is what the
former prime minister said
what the grey report does show is that
number 10 downing street was not
observing the regulations they had
imposed on members of the public
so either my right honourable friend had
not read the rules or didn't understand
what they meant and others around him or
they didn't think the rules applied to
number 10 which was it
i don't think actually that's quite
right in terms of what the sue grey
report did it said that they hadn't
lived up to the standards that would
have been expected but in relation to
specific breaches super
which is not quite what um uh theresa
said but in relation to the 12 specific
instances where there are alleged
breaches those have gone to the police
and it's quite right to wait for them to
conduct that investigation did you
believe in the lockdown that you and
your colleagues championed
yes i did and i think and i thought it
was
yeah absolutely why are the police
investigating 12 separate incidents
that took part in downing street because
if there's any precisely because it's a
lot there is no so let me answer the
question precisely because it's
important precisely because i get the
argument about double standards where
there have been uh allegations claims
assertions that rules have been broken
it is absolutely right that first of all
it was referred to grey and sue grey is
now if there's any potential breach of
the law referred it to the police and
they should look at it and uh we've been
very clear there'll be transparency and
accountability that will follow that
just as there has been with sue gray's
report i know you said that he's got the
support of mps let's listen to this
when he kindly invited me to see him 10
days ago
i told him that i thought he should
think very carefully about what was now
in the best interests of our country and
of the conservative party and i have to
tell him he no longer enjoys my support
aaron bell also said he recounted the
experience of 10 people attending his
grandmother's funeral does the prime
minister think i'm a fool is what he
said
he's losing the house
well okay i think actually if you um
listen to the whole of the two hours the
pm spent in the chamber yes there were
you've picked out the the two uh most
strident critics from the conservative
side i think it's fair to say but
actually i've given you well
three uh tourism and a labour politician
okay but you've given but actually it
was over you know 650 mps in the house
of commons my my feeling was that the pm
uh
the combination of contrition uh
answering the su grey uh
challenge in terms of the problems and
how he's going to fix it but also saying
how he's getting on with the job the
vaccine rollout the economy uh and also
dealing with the situation ukraine and
that is overwhelmingly what mps and i
think our voters and our constituents
want to see him doing in this government
doing and actually the
in the meeting of the parliamentary
party uh which i attended with the pm
and the whole party was there of course
there were questions you'd expect that
but actually people wanted to see this
prime minister getting back on with the
job and recognized the job that he's
done
on the vaccine roll out on the economic
recovery but also the foreign policy
issues that he's dealing with out of
ukraine we'll come to those and this is
what the met police have been saying
they're investigating eight um of 12
dates uh 12 events concerning by cabinet
office alleged gatherings on government
premises during coverage restrictions
received 300 plus images
500 plus pages of information reviewing
materials shall confirm which
individuals will need to be contacted
for their independent
account
who takes 300 images at work events
that's a good question um but i don't
want to get drawn into uh the animus of
those who have put this out there
because actually i think what the public
would say is that um
those are credible um claims that at
least need to be investigated and that's
why the police should do so but you did
say that we will hear more as far as the
full report is concerned in the fullness
of time um does that include the text
messages that the police are looking
into well it depends what i mean of
course both the police and su grey need
to look at the rules that apply to the
privacy and confidentiality of
information that they received but look
at sue grey sends a further report
following the investigation the pm has
been very clear uh it will be published
including the 500 pages of information
that the met are looking into well that
depends what sue grey puts in her report
including the emails that they've been
they're looking into
it's not necessarily the case that they
would uh or sue grey would publish that
but what i'm saying is whatever um sue
gray decides in any follow-up report to
publish the prime minister has been very
clear
that he will okay and uh if he's
interviewed by the police what does that
say about the optics of the uh a sitting
prime minister and his wife being
interviewed by the police he hasn't been
interviewed but by police the police
have said that they will interview
people that were at these events and we
know that the prime minister was at at
least three years you're trying to jump
ahead of the investigation uh i will
actually but if that's not true
i'm going to as i said throughout we
know he was at least three events don't
we and the police have said that they
will investigate anybody or speak to
anybody that was at those events the
sitting prime minister and his wife
being interviewed by the police well
that hasn't happened yet uh uh um okay
nearly called you
i know you did um but look they're both
formidable
because it's true um but the police will
conduct that investigation i'm not going
to start commenting about uh interviews
that haven't taken please have already
commented they've already said that
they're going to investigate people that
were at the parties and we know that the
prime minister was at least three ago
they're going to interview the
parameters i think there's a lot hanging
on your ergo but the the reality is the
police will conduct that investigation
and look you'll be able to ask all those
questions if and when but they said that
after the report and and still sat here
but actually when is it all going to end
well look no one wants it to end uh more
swiftly than i do or the government or
the prime minister but the reality is we
follow if we set up an independent
process you have to follow it but what
the prime minister has shown with the
sugray report published in full he took
two hours of questions in the house of
commons a further out of questions uh
with the parliament it wasn't published
in full shot now that she was frustrated
that it wasn't published in full and she
doesn't trust the prime minister she's
not going to give it to him she's
keeping it under lock and key well uh
i'm not quite sure that those are the
words that she used uh but the report
that she gave him was published in full
and he's been clear any further report
would be published
a little bit of you know the
the prime minister has done exactly what
he said he would exactly what he's been
called to do and he's respecting the
independence of her and the met police
and i'm afraid you can't criticize him
for that um
if he was interfering either with the
sue grey report or with the police
investigation you'll be asking me a
whole series of alternative questions as
i said first prime minister said he
didn't know then it was a work event
then he was told uh it wasn't told it
was a party then he was ambushed with
cake then we was told that we had to
wait for sugray now we have to wait for
the police he knows whether he was at
these parties or not he said he wasn't
at the parties he's misled parliament he
should step down don't accept the leaps
and logic what you're saying but you're
doing a very good job interrogating me
on it i would like to have the answers
but i'm afraid we have to wait for the
police to conclude their investigations
and they've already started it's gone
from 12 to 8 i think according to what
you cited there they're whittling away
to hopefully we'll get wait the police
is wait for the new is that you wait for
sue gray isn't it
well the police are independent in this
country could you imagine if actually i
said i started commenting on what they
would or wouldn't find you'd be hauling
me over the coals in a different way uh
are you surprised that it was a civil
servant that had to find out all this
information rather than the police
well no the the the prime minister asked
her to do it because he could see the
serious seriousness of it so no i'm not
not spicing that knowledge again that it
that is a serious state of affairs the
problem is yeah i do and you're quite
right the problem is we're talking about
this when actually the prime minister
had to postpone and thus cancel a
meeting with putin yesterday no look the
the call sheet for any prime ministers
with any foreign secretary i know i did
the job uh moves around all the time
because you're balancing what you do in
parliament and your other
responsibilities
troops on the border with ukraine
okay let me answer that this prime
minister is the one who has been leading
the transatlantic response with the
united states with
our european uh allies with the most
robust approach on sanctions uh
providing support he's going out to
ukraine to see president of ukraine uh
with the foreign secretary today we're
the ones holding that line uh
galvanizing the support isn't it while
we're waiting for our prime minister to
deal with it
sorry
to deal with the situation in ukraine
okay exactly what i've answered in
relation
and in relation to ukraine actually this
prime minister showed not withstanding
everything that's been going on and it's
significant he's been getting on with
the job on sanctions making sure it's
very clear there'll be a cost to putin
if he continues with this bellicose
behavior and invades ukraine it's taking
it so seriously he still had to cancel a
meeting yesterday a phone call yesterday
with putin because he had to answer
these allegations in the house well look
the the any prime minister any president
it happens all the time their diaries
and their call sheets uh dart around the
place because they're balancing things
um but look you know frankly uh the the
uh the prime minister has been the one
being very clear firming up our european
allies uh bridging with our other nato
allies making sure that we've got robust
sanctions uh and a mechanism for
applying an economic cost and also
making sure we're supporting not just
ukraine but the other nato allies
particularly the baltics in central and
eastern europe who are very nervous now
about their position uh vis-a-vis russia
and yet still the prime minister
couldn't have a conversation with
president putin yesterday because he had
to talk about subaru in the house of
commons look um of course they're always
scheduling issues between any two heads
of government okay um it's always um
interesting to tussle with the lawyer
thank you very much for joining us as
always deputy prime minister thank you
do you fancy the job if
it's that i'm fully supportive of this
prime minister he will go on he'll win
the next election i'm very confident in
that okay we will of course clip that up
thanks very much indeed deputy
apprentice thank you i nearly call you
prime minister then uh let's have a look
at the papers of failure of leadership
says the metro quoting the report they
say boris johnson's premiership has
plunged to a new low
the guardian says that tory backbenchers
have turned on their leader over their
12 gatherings being investigated by the
metropolitan police
the express is headlined yes pm you've
got it wrong now get it right after what
they describe as a bruising day
and the prime minister has zero shame in
the words
excuse me of the daily mirror
someone who knows an awful lot about the
workings of government and parliament is
jack straw he's with us now hello to mr
straw thank you for joining us just
heard the deputy prime minister what did
you make of it
well
dominic grubb was making the best he
could of an impossible wicket
and i mean
i was also foreign for not for two years
but for five years
um
and i i don't recall
more than just a couple of occasions for
really good reasons like serious illness
when tony blair
did not complete the calls to
appropriate head of government or in my
case i didn't complete the call to
uh the appropriate uh foreign minister
what this
it's much worse than a scandal it kind
of rot
in the heart
of the of the government is doing is
also sucking
the life out of the government and
this is extraordinarily
diversionary of
all the kind of work that should be
being done within government um and i
know that uh
prime minister boris johnson is going to
the ukraine today with liz trust the
foreign secretary
and we heard dominic there saying oh
well you know he's been in the lead
on um trying to sort out
uh the ukraine
um
across the world
as you all know from uh the researchers
your people will have done on foreign
press
the united kingdom is a laughingstock
and johnson is not taken seriously at
all
yes he's agreeing with the united states
uh but
why has germany taken a completely
different approach to the ukraine why
isn't president macron uh taking a a a
different view it's partly for their own
internal politics but
in the old days
a british prime minister would have had
a very good fist
at leading the rest of the uh of europe
certainly uh and
pushing the united states president
along and it hasn't happened at all they
take no notice on it
i'm intrigued to know your take on
one of the points i was discussing with
the deputy prime minister former foreign
secretary um just like you and
um i'd made the point that this should
have been a phone call yesterday between
boris johnson and putin he said that
these schedules are moved all the time
and it's absolutely nothing to read into
that just because he was in the chamber
talking about sue gray you know it can
happen another time is that a reasonable
response
well um they're not moved all the time
like this i mean this was a big deal it
was a particularly big deal for bryce
johnson to have his breast people
announce
that he johnson was talking not just to
a head of government but to a head of
state in
vladimir putin
um it shows
further evidence if you like of sort of
congenital systemic
chaos in downing street i mean
didn't somebody think about the fact
that if they were going to have a call
with
putin it might be a good idea not to
schedule it
at the time of sue gray's report since
moscow is three or four hours depending
on time of year ahead
of london
why didn't they have it in the morning
um before sue grey's report
was received
or and just say we're terribly sorry
just as you they you mr putin can't make
it um
in in your hours of darkness which is
different from ours um
we can't make it for reasons we don't
need to disclose
um
on monday afternoon and uh
monday evening
um so
it is
say aside from the humiliation
that he hasn't been able to uh do his
job as prime minister which is on
foreign policy talk to heads of
government uh it's just a reflection of
somebody just not having a you know not
not getting the idea
that there could be a problem and
the two two things won't work you can't
be in the house of commons i'm taking a
call from vladimir putin
sorry
um
how weary should we be about what's
happening on the border with ukraine
we should be
pretty worried i mean
it's very difficult to say whether
um
this will
situation will result in a russian
invasion because i think russia realizes
that
the price of that in non-military terms
and maybe in military terms is going to
be very intense and um it had the
experience i mean let me say as as the
uk and the u.s and others did as well of
getting bogged down in afghanistan
that was for 10 years
excuse me
and will it want to get bogged down
again
so i
but i i mean i think
i'm
more optimistic than i was
and indeed as each day passes i think
the
prospect of a russian invasion will
diminish but it's still there
and it depends on keeping the pressure
up and showing the ukrainians that we
that we are supporting them
okay um what's your advice to liz trust
she's got covered at the moment so she
can't head over to ukraine with the uh
prime minister she can't go to moscow
what sort of diplomacy can you carry out
from behind your desk
um
oh you can do quite a lot particularly
the crucial thing about um
phone calls and these days zoom causing
and team calls
uh in diplomacy is you need to have
built up
the relationships first
uh and it's not that much different from
normal human relations so
if she's got a good relations with other
foreign ministers
then she'll be able to make the calls
and sometimes you have to make the calls
and you've never met the people in in
your life
um but
i mean i think
liz should spend more time thinking
about the ukraine and rather less time
thinking about the next post she puts on
instagram uh
as part of her
putative leadership bid which i think
for her
uh i say to a search later someone in
europe quite well
as as well as the country is a mistake
she says uh that the prime minister has
her wholehearted support and she has no
interest in being prime minister i know
people always say that
uh i mean
it's it's um
uh
and
i mean the truth is that
boris johnson will have
this trust his wholehearted support
until boris johnson is not there
um and um well he knows in the secret
secrecy of the ballot
of the conservative parliamentary party
if there is a ballot how liz trusts or
dominic robb
uh will vote but i'd if i i mean i
watched dominic
face your very difficult questions and
give them
in a sense the best known answers he
could think of
but what the government's having to
think about
is that this is going to go on and on
and on
and every time anything
happens
whatever the subject is
they see will be
understandably shifting
and shifted by the journalists or by
opposition mps onto the prime minister's
behavior i mean i do not really i can't
think
uh of
uh
any other occasion in in my lifetime um
when a prime minister
has
faced this level of
destabilization of his own choosing
so and so whatever uh boris john
sorry dominic rabo let's trust say about
the fact that they will give their prime
minister full support well they do for
the time being
they will get more and more fed up with
this and it's not in my view going to go
away
um
it is
down to the uh backbenchers and it is um
you know his other conservative
colleagues as well isn't it because
labour does not have a big enough uh
majority even uh with other flavors of
politics as well from the house of
commons and so it's up to the
conservatives uh to decide whether he
stays in power or not and it certainly
looks as though for now he still has
their backing what does that say about
the conservatives um to that side of the
house
well
the i i mean i think there are some i
mean i know there are very very many
perfectly decent conservatives
we saw
examples of those in theresa may and
andrew mitchell
yesterday
who are absolutely appalled by this
um and i mean i'm not you know we have
lots of difficulties in government you
do including afghanistan and
above all iraq but i we've never had
and i've never sold it on the other side
i didn't see it with margaret thatcher
or john major
or david cameron
this kind of
personal
uh
failure of character which is eating
away
at the government
but
so i do apologize i was taken by my own
phrases and forgot your question
you know what that's happened to me
twice in two days now by former of
foreign secretaries for the labour party
i i thought i was doing quite well i was
basically asking about the moral fiber
of conservatives on that side of the
house you don't want to get rid of the
leader what does it say about them well
they'll have to make their own minds up
about this about where their interests
lie
um the crucial thing everybody has to
think about the house of confidence
above all else is staying there
how do you stay there i that means how
do you get reelected uh and you can't
take any seat for granted i mean we
found that
last at last the last election in
december 2019
when
we lost catastrophically a number of
seats which frankly the labour party and
particularly awful
egregious jeremy corbyn had taken for
granted
and the conservatives will find the same
i mean back in 1997
um
we won uh most of the seats in essex
it's my home county i know it very well
um
and they just the conservative seats
went down like flies and
so
and bear in mind that
since the
conservatives have
only a handful of seats like as we do
in scotland there and and they're in a
minority in wales
they're
very very dependent for their majority
of what happens in english
seats and in
in a lot of the so-called red wool seeds
we already know
that there is fury
about the way in which uh boris johnson
has taken the british public and the
voters in those areas for fools so
i think a few more weekends
where uh members of parliament
particularly new ones who've given mr
johnson his majority
getting their head scrubbed uh by their
voters may see a ship if it doesn't
um it will just tell me that the
conservatives have lost the will to
survive and i don't actually think
that's true
so why uh labor flailing at the polls
again
failing at the polls i probably missed
something this morning
uh yeah so the latest polls are
suggesting that the lead that uh labor
had has been cut in half in other words
i suppose the other way of looking at
that is that
people are either deciding that they
prefer boris johnson um to kia stammer
or they're bored with the su grey story
well we're still editing the polls i
mean it would be pretty surprising if if
we weren't um
they will bob up and down and no one
says that when when
you're below uh
the other side in the in the polls i
personally uh think that kierstama has
done well and the public have been able
to
see
uh this man for the the man of values uh
that he is uh and compare and contrast
him uh with mr johnson
and i when we there'll be a by-election
uh on thursday uh but that's to do with
the murder of sir david amis and i don't
think we'll get anything out of that not
least because
the main parties aren't standing there
um but i'm pretty optimistic about the
results of the may elections and if you
want we can have a side bet on that
and i'd love to come on the following
week and eat humble pie
[Laughter]
what did you make of what ian blackford
got up to yesterday rules his rules you
know you can't expect the prime minister
to abide by rules and then the leader of
the snp
mr blackford is the kind of pantomime
character really oh no he isn't
oh yes he is
but did he do the right thing you know
he would say he's a man of conviction
yeah you can make a conviction point
without having to break the rules that's
my view i'm afraid i'm i've got a great
little time for the scottish national
party uh nationalist party i mean they
all
all things to all people provided
they're complaining
and pitching themselves uh against the
english and taking more money
from english taxpayers than english
taxpayers get for themselves and then
complaining some more
and one day
although it has been a very long time
coming and there's been a labor failure
in scotland um
the snp support will twist and fall
okay good to talk to you um thank you so
much for joining us again jack straw
always a pleasure thank you thank you
very much
thank you
well boris johnson promised to fix the
way downing street operates after sue
gray's a report found a serious failure
in party leadership but tensions rose as
the pm repeatedly dodged questions about
partygate
his best course is simply to wait for
the uh for the inquiry to be complete i
urge him to to reconsider upon full
consideration of the of the inquiry we
should wait for the outcome of the
inquiry by before jumping to the
conclusions uh that he has i propose
that we wait until the conclusion of the
of the inquiry i must really ask him to
look at the uh report properly and also
to wait uh for the inquiry when it comes
i would simply urge him to wait for the
outcome of the of the inquiry that's
what he needs to do it's now time for
the police to consider the relevant
material and that is what the house
should allow them frankly to do
former senior police officer has accused
cressida dick of launching a nonsense
inquiry into partygate over minor
offenses die davis and some conservative
mps say the investigation was a
deplorable waste of public money given
the scale of crime and violent attacks
in london and the former chief of
scotland yard's royal protection command
die davis joining us now hello to thank
you so much for joining us on the
program this morning um
what's your view as far as this
investigation is uh concerned the amount
of evidence that the met is going to
have to go through
well good morning to you uh in the court
of public opinion i think they've been
found guilty okay
already the prime minister that is and
some of his senior colleagues
it now remains to see out of this
quagmire a mess what the police will do
and what concerns me is the fact is that
no matter what evidence has already been
presented that was obtained by a civil
servant not a police officer and i
wonder how much of that can be induced
in evidence if this was a proper
criminal inquiry but of course it isn't
it is the equivalent of investigating uh
parking in one sense on yellow lines but
of course it's far more than that and
what may come out if people tell little
lies big lies often follow look at
prince andrew look at mr bashir all
manner of people start off with
relatively small
lies and then they get found out so i
wonder what on earth will now happen
to this investigation but
it is a mess by any definition
you've described it as nonsense do you
still stand by that
well nonsense in the sense that it's uh
started at this stage i would have
thought if miss gray had relevant
information which took it into criminal
investigation perhaps that should have
been done much earlier before any of
these 400 people who allegedly work
at
number 10 actually were interviewed i
understand 70 have but again they were
interviewed as i understand it under
civil service rules which are quite
different to the police investigating
you so how much of that so-called
information 500 photos and all the rest
of it could be induced in evidence if
the police are going to make a factual
report i think they left it far far too
late in my humble opinion
okay good to talk to you thank you so
much for joining us on the program this
morning mr davies with your expert uh
guidance thank you
my pleasure
thank you kirstama's here um your
thoughts after yesterday
well
uh we only had part of the story from
sue grey obviously but it was a pretty
damning part of the story we know that
of the 12 parties or gatherings that she
was investigating of the 16 she was
investigating 12 of them are going to
the police for investigation because the
police have assessed that they're
serious enough and flagrant enough
to put on one side the usual rule that
they won't look at things more than 12
months ago so it's as damning as it
could be and you know we're all paying
the price for the chaos and incompetence
and worse of the prime minister and his
behavior and now we need to wait
for the police report we've got to wait
for the police to investigate so we've
got a prime minister who
i think broke the rules
i think then lied about breaking the
rules who then instigated the sue grey
report and has now brought a criminal
investigation upon himself
and that is about as damning as it can
get for a british prime minister of
whatever political party
meanwhile meanwhile
people are seeing their energy bills go
up but nothing is being done about it
and so
there was a real range of emotions
yesterday in the house because i think
the one thing that the last six seven
weeks
of allegations about the prime
minister's behavior have done is forced
everybody to relive
moments in their own lives in the last
two years those sort of dark moments and
people have felt
angry
they felt grief and
and they felt guilt and i've had so many
people say to me here i feel guilty
because i followed the rules
i didn't do what i wanted to do in my
heart go look after my dad clean up
look after an elderly relative and i've
i feel guilty that i didn't do it
because i was obeying the rules and
people feel that they've been taken for
mugs
there's now a further emotion which is
frustration which is why energy bills
are going up and the government's doing
absolutely nothing about it
now we the labour party have said we'll
cut those energy bills we've set out how
we would fund that with a windfall tax
on oil and gas
we want the government to get on with it
we've got a motion this afternoon in
parliament to be voted on
um but the prime minister is spending
all of his time saving his own skin
instead of running the country isn't he
a lawyer i mean given that you are a
lawyer he certainly isn't um isn't he
innocent until proven guilty
well of course he is but um
judging him
we got to an absurd situation yesterday
where he was asked a very simple
question
were you at the party in your own flat
on the 30th of november 2020
and he says i can't answer that because
there's police investigation that is
nonsense when that president is the
police investigation how does it
prejudice the police investigation for
him to admit that he was at a party in
his own flat i'm sorry that is bordering
on the ridiculous because he could have
gone through that he lives there he
could be in one of the bedrooms there
could be something going on elsewhere
and he wouldn't even know about it you
know a bit like when he went into the
garden he didn't know that that was the
gathering and when he knew then he left
and he didn't know he was totally
ambushed by the cake he didn't know that
that was going to be a birthday yeah
apparently he went into the garden and
there were bottles of wine and trellises
of
of sandwiches and lots of people
drinking and he didn't realize it was a
party until he was 20 sure he was trying
to run the country at the time we were
in the middle of a pandemic you know one
of the things that has angered people
most over the last few weeks is one they
know he broke the rules
two they think he's insulting their
intelligence with these ridiculous
defenses and he's also forcing all of
his front benches ministers out onto
your programs and others
to make complete fools of themselves
peddling these absurd defenses isn't
that up to them well it is up to them
but meanwhile we've got an energy bill
crisis which isn't being addressed
and that is why we've had a proposal on
the table to reduce energy bills for um
several weeks now the government is
doing absolutely nothing about it and
whilst they're trying to save his skin
he was supposed to have a meeting with
the chancellor last week about energy
bills it got cancelled because he needed
to spend his time with his own
backbenchers saving his own job
families there for not getting reduction
on their energy bill and labour has
stepped up to say we've got a plan we've
got a costed plan we want to move it
forward whilst you are
mired in this misbehavior we are we are
putting the case for a new britain built
on security prosperity and respect and
we will continue to make that case and i
invite all tory mps this afternoon if
they really want to move this on and
focus on energy bills vote with us this
afternoon to reduce the bills for
millions of families across the country
yeah well as you know if i had a
conservative mp sitting there they'd be
telling me about the vaccine roll out
and be telling me about how well the
economy is doing they'll be telling me
about how well the furlough scheme went
so you know let's let's put that to one
side if we may and talk about
specifically about what people are
concerned about which is the sugray
report and whether that is in enough for
the prime minister to step down the
prime minister says no it's not it does
look as though his backbenchers are
agreeing with him when you looked over
at them yesterday in the house of
commons how did you feel i looked at
their fa the one thing there aren't many
advantages being the dispatch box but as
you step forward to the dispatch box
all the sort of friendly faces are
behind you and you've got a wall of
of the government faces
their faces were stony
they were not with him they know how
serious this is
um
and and i think that they're ashamed of
the prime minister and you can you can
see very well when they're with him and
when they're not with him and you heard
some of what those on his own side said
yesterday about his behavior they know
that
you know successive prime ministers
whether they're you know conservative
whether their labor have honored the
office they've recognized that to lead
this country is an honor
it's not a birthright and and and i
think they're ashamed of this prime
minister okay this is this was the scene
um yesterday he did have um some uh
support some of them stood up um to
speak um in his support and there was a
lot of nodding from the um front benches
as you said i mean
what would you say to the front bench of
the government this morning
they know that this can't this prime
minister cannot be removed unless they
act
um i think he's unfit for office and i
think they should act and remove this
prime minister is not fit for his
responsibilities
and they've got a choice they either do
that or they carry on debasing
themselves and going out into the
studios peddling his absurd defenses
they have to go out
and make the argument that their prime
minister didn't realize he was at a
party with bottles and sandwiches for
half an hour they have to come and sit
on your show and make that argument they
know it's not true they know it's not
credible i think they are debasing
themselves and debasing their office
they are also not getting on with the
job because they're spending the whole
of their time defending a prime minister
who is indefensible okay you talked
about wine and sandwiches we need to
deal with this photograph as well of you
with beer and bodies back in durham i
think it was april of 2020. um if you
if you were sue gray would you want to
investigate that i've explained this
photograph which actually came out a
couple of days after it was taken so
many times we were in a constituency
office working it was a few days before
the local elections
and we had nothing to eat a takeaway
came and we ate we stopped to eat the
takeaway and then we went back to work
that is the long and the short of it
there is no breach of the rules there
was no party there's nothing to
investigate and you'd be happy for the
police to look into that in more detail
well look the
police are now looking at 12 of the 16
allegations having assessed them to be
serious there is no breach of the rule
there yeah it's been you so you will be
happy absolutely nothing to hide at all
i've explained it so many times even the
prime minister has now backed off
attacking so you would be happy
no problem there's no breach of the
rules okay i didn't understand what the
prime minister was talking about
yesterday when he brought up jimmy
savile what's all that about it is a
ridiculous slur peddled by right-wing
trolls
and um
the disgust and this is where i saw the
faces of the conservative mps the
disgust on their faces
that their prime minister
was debasing himself by sinking solo in
the chamber was clear
you know
they knew
that he was going so low with that slur
with that lie um he'd been advised not
to do it because it's obviously not true
but he does it because he doesn't
understand what honesty and integrity
means when i was director of public
prosecutions
i was superintendent by the attorney
general conservative attorney general so
it is as ridiculous as it gets and
and i'm glad that those tourist mps were
disgusted and many of them expressed
that to me discussed at their prime
minister for debasing himself in the
house of commons instead of acting with
the contrition and the integrity that he
should have shown yesterday he does what
he always does which is to try to drag
everybody into the gutter with him the
one thing we know about this prime
minister is everybody who's ever come
into contact with him
always gets damaged in the process i've
been working in politics for a very long
time first election i ever covered was
1979 when margaret thatcher won
and i am used to politicians not liking
each other particularly but they always
use the language of diplomacy you you've
decided to put that away now i i'm not
one of these politicians that is so
tribal that i won't
reach out and form partnerships even
friendships with conservative mps many
of them i know i like and i get along
with and i think that is my reputation
in parliament but when i see a prime
minister lacking the basic honesty and
integrity
uh for the job of prime minister then
i'm sorry that's a step too far for me
whatever the color whatever the party of
that prime minister does it make you
think you know i don't want to be
involved in politics anymore if we've
got this guy in charge it's not for me
no it makes me even more determined that
we must make sure this prime minister is
gone he's debasing the officer of office
of prime minister he's just got to go
okay um do you think that he should
face face-to-face in
inquiries from the police
oh well i mean it's up to the police now
how they conduct their investigations
um and they may well need to interview
him that's a matter for them and i don't
think i should be telling them how to do
their job in that respect how long do
you think it's going to take i hope not
long it's a very simple offense
how many people were there was there a
reasonable excuse so it's a lot of
evidence though there's 500 pages and
300 photographs a lot of photographs for
a work event but here we are there are a
lot of photographs and um often a
picture tells a thousand uh words so
pages of a thousand words so you know
we'll see what they say okay let me just
ask you before you go um
it was a very challenging time for a lot
of people the pandemic for you in
particular i mean
you found it very difficult as far as
the family was concerned didn't you
i did we did
and um
you know my wife lost her mum just
before the pandemic and it was a very
very difficult time for her
and we as a family had our struggles
and she had her struggles
i prefer not to go into them in great
detail because i always try to protect
the privacy of my family but one of the
reasons that i said yesterday that every
family was marked by this
is because we as a family were marked by
it what we didn't do because we followed
the rules and the grief
that that brought in and and the guilt
that that brought upon us and do you
regret about him by the rules now given
what you know was potentially happening
at downing street i think millions of
people feel that they
they were mugs people tossed and turned
at night thinking i should have done
that for my family member i should have
gone in and cleaned up i should have
hugged i should have done something in
the situation
but they didn't because they were
following the rules
and certainly there are elements of that
in my own family
i think every family had elements of
that and now they do look back and feel
you know that they were mugs they
shouldn't they should know they
shouldn't they should feel
pride
pride that what they did probably saved
the lives of people they will never meet
and that is the real story
of our country through this pandemic and
the great tragedy now as it's stained by
this prime minister and by his behavior
so kira i must let you go thank you very
much indeed for joining us we appreciate
you taking the time thank you